[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Cinco de Mayo
it's here are you celebrating the Friday
too holy [__] Cinco de Mayo on a Friday
I mean a lot of drunk some [__] I'm
just saying
maybe people would be drunk with power
too in this country
if they're able to buy Supreme Court
Justices as the saga continues
I promise you we did not plan
on
um because we put Clarence Thomas on the
bonehead of the week
lo and behold
I [__] knew what are you gonna do I
don't
hell
you can buy the Supreme Court in Supreme
Court decisions apparently Leo Leonard
uh
Paige Genie Thomas through kellyanne
Conway
for a 5-4 decision that struck down
voting rights of course
of course
why do you think chief justice Roberts
doesn't want to go before the Senate
hmm
folks there's there's a lot at stake
in this country
and for far too long
people who believe in democracy they
truly believe in the institutions of
democracy
are tired of the corruption
are tired of the elites
like Jeannie Thomas Clarence Thomas
kellyanne Conway Leo Leonard
tired of Elites telling us what we can
and cannot do
with our democracy
this this story this morning of
kellyanne Conway
be being the go-between for a payment of
Jeannie Thomas Genie Thomas not not
Clarence they weren't paying a Supreme
Court Justice only his wife
get the [__] out of here with this
[__] man come on are you are you
really gonna try to she's an activist
she's been an activist for years I
wonder why she is hmm could it be that
her husband is a Supreme Court Justice
that way they can funnel money through
her as if it's an activist to him get
[__] you man we're not that [__]
stupid the American people may be
ignorant of a lot of things but they
know [__] when they see [__]
kellyanne she was on Fox news this
morning trying to Gaslight us [__] you
[__] [__] you you can go straight to
[__] hell
straight to [__] hell you scumbag
it's enough of us not just saying the
[__] out loud it's enough of it this
story this morning isn't isn't an
example of our Democratic institutions
failing it it is the example of elitist
in our country Republican elitist not
not not [__] liberal elitist they're
trying to take away voting rights they
were trying to take rights away from you
this is what it [__] looks like
and I'm sure people are gonna say oh
well this is just an example of why why
are democracy
you see it no it's not an example why
our democracies [__] it's an example why
we the Democracy should [__] pay
attention to the Republic the people
representing us
and hold them [__] accountable to
hold other [__] accountable
especially 100 full stop from here on
out Republicans it's enough of this [__]
you you dumb [__] have been
bitching about a two-tier justice system
that's going after Donald Trump and what
you're really [__] pissed off about
is your second tier of justice is no
longer gonna protect you
and it shouldn't [__] you there is a
two-tier justice system in this country
and we sh it shouldn't be that way we
should tear it down and if Donald Trump
is the example that fine [__] it let it
be that
and make Clarence Thomas and Jeannie
Thomas the next example [__] them
it's enough of this garbage
so not for this that that these people
can call us elitist can call liberals
people who want equality and Liberty and
freedom and rights for everyone calling
us to [__] elitist you you son of a
[__] [__]
and I'm not saying anything the audience
doesn't [__] want to say even the
haters out there if you're listening to
me and you're mad about me speaking out
against Leo Leonard having a [__]
court case before The Supreme Court to
take away people's [__] rights to
vote
paying kellyanne Conway to pay Genie
Thomas to make Clarence Thomas have a
certain decision and if you're mad at me
you you are the [__] problem
you are the brainwashed delusional
problem that we have in this country you
stupid bastard
we are not against you you are supposed
to be on our side against the [__]
corrupt Elite deep state which is
Republicans you stupid bastards
pluck your [__] head out of your ass
and see it dummy you manga idiots really
are [__] brainwashed mind [__] into
believing that the real true deep state
is somehow being oppressed by the Deep
state
they they are the ones trying to oppress
you you [__] idiot
Missouri prime example Missouri all the
[__] all the [__] male legislators
up there at Missouri boy they want to
pass laws to make sure pregnant women
can't get divorced and there's no
consent divorce in this country and I
can tell you one thing for sure I know
it I've seen it these [__] out
at bars at night
legislators at bars at night married
family God country Jesus Christian
values trying to pick up on women and
now now they're trying to pass laws in
the Missouri legislator saying hey you
can't divorce me if I don't give you
consent I wonder why that is
you you stupid [__] white Christian
nationalists that have bought into this
[__]
that somehow liberalism is the correct
part of our democracy you are a stupid
[__]
and you really need to do some soul
searching dummy
because you are propping up the elite is
what you're doing
not challenging them
not holding the elitist accountable like
Elon Musk get the [__] out of here Eon
is an elite
shut the [__] up man enough of your
nonsense we are sick and tired of your
[__] gaslighting your lies and your
stupid [__] delusion
it's enough of this garbage we do not
have to put up with this as a democracy
we do not
we get to hold these son of a [__]
accountable and how we do that is with
our vote and I know you're going to say
well Tony the choices are Slim
what you can choose not to vote for the
[__] Republican elitist
you can make that simple choice to start
what does it say in the beginning of the
show what does it say it says the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty
Leo Leonard
gets his case of his group
oh it's not actually him Tony see it's a
non-profit that he has that that he
funds that's what it is it's not
actually him get the [__] out of here
you you people are making excuses
for these elitist Republican elitist
these [__] real America First Nazis
and this isn't something that happened
yesterday Jesus Christ Kelly and
Conway's on Fox News like this is
something that happened 10 years ago so
what
yeah even worse even worse you [__]
[__]
even worse
that you've been trying to bang up our
democracy with corruption
for years this decision
struck down parts of the Voting Rights
Act
a turning point in our nation
that gave disenfranchised voters the
right to vote the first time in
centuries ever in some cases you
[__] and it prevented white
racist in the south from changing
[__] laws
to take away people's [__] rights you
dirty [__] and when you stand
when you stand with the people who will
take away people's rights they're coming
for yours too
I don't care if you're a white man
I don't give a [__] if you're a straight
white man if you're a straight white man
you should be the loudest
not capitulating to the system
not standing back because your rights
may be the last to go [__] you
and by you being silent and not saying
anything I don't give a [__] what your
affiliation is I don't care if you wear
a [__] Maga hat I don't give a [__]
if you fly a trump flag if you're not
speaking out this morning about this
[__] that we're finding out about
Jeannie Thomas Clarence Thomas kellyanne
Conway and the [__] deep State
Republican elitist like Leo Leonard
taking away people's [__] rights
through through Supreme Court battles
then you're not American [__]
you're a traitor
to the rest of the country to your
[__] countrymen
it's the least you could do when you're
yelling and screaming about the Deep
State and Corruption Hunter Biden's
laptop Hunter Biden was paid this and he
was paid that he was never a Supreme
Court Justice [__] his wife
isn't a Supreme Court Justice
he isn't making decisions that take away
rights from people
if you can yell and scream about that
you damn well better bet you can yell
and scream about the corruption that
we're finding out about this morning at
the Supreme Court level with Leo Leonard
kellyanne Conway Jeannie Thomas and
Clarence Thomas he needs to go now
resign [__] and if not we we the
people will vote people in that will
impeach your dumb ass it's time
it's time I don't give a [__] what
Justice and if any of the justices
Democrat or Republicans stand in the way
you're gone too [__] you
I can't believe that those [__]
justices signed that letter
Kagan sort of more oh you that's slimy
[__] I'm pissed the [__] off
you better form a letter and stop
defending these pieces of [__]
that are taking payments to make
decisions on the Supreme Court even the
appearance is too much
thomason's an activist
no she's a money funnel to the Supreme
Court is what she is
she's a q Anon cultist at best
believing delusional [__] lies
propagating them
funding the Insurrection arrest her ass
it's enough of the [__]
and just because you're mad that your
two-tier justice system isn't going to
protect you anymore you think we're
gonna give a [__]
because they're right folks they're
right when these Republicans that are
out there simping for Donald Trump are
like ah there's a two-tiered justice
system in this country
yeah there is
and we're advocating for the two-tier
justice system to not protect these
corrupt [__] anymore
and Donald Trump is just one example of
that Jeannie Thomas and Clarence Thomas
and kellyanne Conway is the next [__]
them
not for this [__] garbage
took money thousands tens of thousands
of dollars
took money
from Leo Leonard who brought a [__]
decision to the Supreme Court in a 5-4
vote to take away people's rights to
vote
and to make sure that states could bang
up their rights to vote
to strike down the Civil Rights Act the
vote the Voting Rights Act excuse me
and you [__] Maga Trump supporters
who are gonna be like I work for Freedom
we're for America we hate the Deep state
we hate elitist
we think there's corruption and you're
gonna defend them
it just shows how [__] dumb you are
it really does it shows how stupid you
are and how how much your your your sh
you are the sheep that are following the
the [__] wolves to slaughter you
dummies
you dumb [__] man
so go ahead be my guest
have at it
oh boy I think we're gonna have a great
show for you today yeah yeah we're going
to talk more about this this uh during
the bonehead of the week again I didn't
exactly plan this to be the headline of
the day or I never plan the headline of
the day I just [__] comment on it I
don't get to plan these things
this isn't my plan what do you want me
to do
I'm just here to give you the cold hard
facts in a real raw way why do you want
me I don't know and the way that you
would probably say him if if you were
allowed to say them this way
a lot of people aren't allowed to talk
the way I talk they're not I understand
that I get that that's why I do it the
way I do it
that's why
I understand that a lot of people come
here for the cathartic release who the
[__] is going to tell me what to say or
what to do huh who
nobody there ain't no one telling me and
if there is someone to tell me what to
say and what to do guess what I'm gonna
tell them you can [__] off
I'm your voice that's what I am
and yeah and sometimes you may disagree
with me that's fine there's nothing
wrong with that hell I disagree with a
lot of people in the chat sometimes
there's nothing wrong with it there's
nothing wrong with disagreement that's
[__] human nature
that's our Liberty to disagree with each
other
that's our Liberty that's what it is
we have we have we have the right in
this country to disagree
we have the right to have stupid really
dumb ideas
we have the right to have unpopular
ideas we have the right to have popular
ideas
we can believe just about anything you
want Jesus Christ there's people running
around amongst us that you think are
smart that believe the Earth is flat
they've been brainwashed into thinking
this [__]
they think aliens created the pyramids
and [__] they think Bigfoot's real
and that's not even the craziest type of
conspiracy theories that are out there
[__] they think JFK is Junior's still
alive and he's going to be the vice
president or some [__]
I don't know
pick out any of the Maga Q Anon
conspiracy theories
and it doesn't sound too far-fetched
that aliens created the pyramids and the
Earth is flat touch it
but it's your right to be stupid
but it's also our right to tell you how
dumb you are and how dumb you sound
and how ridiculous you're you are when
you're being gaslighted
lit is it gaslighted or glass glass
glass gas lit which is it or am I just
too much of a [__] hillbilly
I don't know [__] I don't know
if anyone thinks I'm faking it it is I'm
just a redneck I'm just a bumpkin that's
what it is
I just I just don't normally say the
things that bum can say
and the reason why is because I use that
thing between my ears
and I I give a little bit more of a [__]
about other people
than just myself
and I believe that my actions against
other people reflect on me
I do I believe that am I perfect no who
the [__] is if you think you're perfect
you that's your imperfection
that is exactly your imperfection if you
think you're perfect and Almighty and
nothing can happen that's that's it
that's the thing that makes you not
perfect then there's probably a whole
list of things after that
yeah
and we're never going to have Perfection
there's no Utopia
to hope for
people in this country want simple
things
and one of those simple things is
Liberty
it truly is
and I know I pound this drum all the
time but we have to keep pounding this
drum
we have to keep speaking about what
matters and what what brings a coalition
together
we can't divide amongst ourselves of the
of people who believe in the
institutions of democracy
even people who say they don't believe
in democracy to some level they're full
of [__]
and at that level
at that level we can coalesce
we really can come together to change
the entire Paradigm of what our
democracy means and what Liberty means
to us
but we have to stop having fights about
[__] that isn't going to change that
paradigm
and until we get there we can't have
discussions we can't compromise on
certain things it's not going to work
thank you
if we don't have Democrats elected in
state legislators to compromise they're
going to be compromising rather a woman
can get divorced from a man without
consent
like in Missouri or rather she if she's
what are you do they take pregnancy
tests now if a woman wants to file
divorce if a pregnant woman can't get
divorced do they have to take a
pregnancy test to file for a divorce
that's my question sounds like that's
what they want to do especially when
they're you can't be pregnant and you
don't have consent
also in Missouri they want to marry 12
year old girls it seems like a lot of
this stuff about taking away rights from
people is aimed at I don't know women
seems kind of convenient doesn't it
I'm the same on the same token I was
talking to one of my friends yesterday I
used that term loosely I know this
person I I I I don't think they're a
dumb person but they definitely are mind
[__] by the right-wing media
and mind [__] by their white right
white might maybe white right-wing
friends
about trans issues
we were having a back and forth about
the Bud Light thing and I said she
posted on her Instagram account and
immediately triggered this person to
correct me about the pronoun I said you
know it's really funny that you
corrected me about the pronoun that
you're the one focused on the [__]
pronoun and immediately let me know that
Dylan what genitalia Dylan Mulvaney had
and I said how do you know have you have
you checked this out have you do you
know something I don't I don't know
Dylan mulmaney that well
I I don't follow her on social media I
didn't even really know who she was and
tell the whole Bud Light thing blew up
but he was hyper focused on her
genitalia and I said you know and he
said it's a it's a mental illness I said
you know it is a mental illness when you
you [__] can't think about
anything else but someone's genitalia
especially a woman's they're not focused
on men's genitalia I mean unless they're
comparing it to their own and then
theirs is much bigger than theirs it's
really it's weird [__] it's it is a
mental illness these people are [__]
weird
but the these people are voting
these people are are gaining seats in
our in our state houses
they're passing laws
policy these unserious weirdos
are passing laws that we all have to
abide by whether you [__] like it or
not so yeah am I a little [__] upset
when straight white men are gonna
capitulate because uh I'm the last one
that the rights are going to be taking
I'm listen none of these laws that I
speak out against none of this [__]
that I speak out against I'm the last
one that it's gonna affect people the
last [__]
I'm white I'm a man
I'm I'm not I'm not a retirement age
I don't have military benefits
that I've earned
that are going to be taken away from me
I'm the last [__] that they're
gonna be able to take something away
from and I mean unless I keep speaking
in this microphone the way I do
but that's the only thing they got on me
that's it that's the only thing they
hate about me that's it
but I speak out against it because I
think my privilege
the [__] responsibility of it is to
smash it up use my privilege like a
hammer to smash it up
until we get Liberty for all people in
this country and yeah it's a hard fight
I don't even know that it'll happen the
amount of equality and Equity that I
would would like to see in our country
and empathy and compassion that I would
like to see in our country I don't I
don't know that that level will be
achieved in my lifetime I don't know I
hope so but I don't know
it's gonna be a tough fight
but it's up to you it really is up to
you and I know you say well I'm just one
person well so am I
so am I I'm just one person
but we can all do something I do
something with with what I am given
my ability to to convey a message
to sit here for two hours and yell and
scream as as you get the cathartic
release whether you're at work right now
quietly listening or you're at home and
I'm on your TV
or I'm I'm somehow being as a as a
recording you're listening to me now
when you're cooking dinner
or the day after when you're taking your
walk
I know what I was given
and I'm trying to use it
as part of the pro-democracy Coalition
and I know you will too
and for all you hate listeners out there
again if you're not absolutely [__]
pissed about the deep deep State kind of
[__]
that was being reported this morning and
then and then kellyanne Conway going on
Fox News an absolutely gaslighting your
dumb asses and you believing every
single word of that [__] horseshit
that she said on Fox news this morning
you are a stupid [__] to believe that
somehow all it was was just Jeannie
Thomas is an activist
it had nothing to do with funneling
money at their exact right time so that
Clarence Thomas would make the decision
that Leo Leonard needed him to make to
win his case so that that way they could
press back on people's people colors
rights to vote in Southern States
foreign
and all you're doing is just pissing us
off that's all you're doing
so join us I'm telling you look listen
Maga you you you [__] q and honors
out there as crazy as you are We're not
gonna turn you away if you're like you
know what [__] that [__] I was lied to
I was lied to there is there is
corruption in this country and the
people that are corrupt were the ones
that convinced me
that it was liberal democracy that is
corrupt
we welcome you come join us come on
come join us I'm telling you
we don't give a [__] what your Creed we
don't care what your color we don't care
what your religion we don't give a [__]
we don't even care that you're once
delusional we don't care it's not
something we give a [__] about come on
over I mean we might be suspicious for a
little bit
but you be genuine and authentic about
it
you're welcome in our coalition
against these corrupt [__]
because democracy is the institution
that is going to shed light on this
it's going to give transparency to the
corrupt and yes there is a two-tier
justice system that Donald Trump and his
allies are talking about
and we do not want it to protect them
anymore
that's what we want
in the pro-democracy Coalition and you
can hear it every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch do not forget to subscribe to
the YouTube channel right now you don't
want to miss a single episode if you do
you can download it the audio version
and you should be downloading the audio
version anyways it helps out the show
did you know that it helps out the show
if you go into Apple's Spotify Google
and download doesn't cost you a single
thing doesn't cost you a nickel if
you're on Facebook you can launch it as
well at the Tony Michaels catch us out
over there you can vote on Twitter for
bonehead of the week it's Friday we got
bone end of the week
at Tony Michael's Pond you can vote
there and on the YouTube Channel's
Community page also if you want to give
us monetary support for free that's
right I said it if you want to give
money to the show without costing you a
single nickel if you're an Amazon Prime
subscriber listen up
if you have an Amazon Prime subscription
all you have to do is link your Amazon
Prime account to your Twitch account
give us that one free subscription that
you get on Twitch
with your Amazon Prime account that's
right
if you have Amazon Prime they give you
one free subscription every single month
to a Creator on Twitch a streamer as
they call it over there a streamer on
Twitch and if you link the two together
and you give us that one free
subscription it doesn't cost you a
dollar but it cost Amazon money they
give us a few bucks for that
subscription every single month and you
have to renew it every month so if
you've done it before
and you you need to renew it every month
to give us that couple bucks every month
and we appreciate everyone over on
Twitch the other thing on Twitch that
doesn't cost you a nickel is following
us so go follow us on Twitch that even
if you're not an Amazon Prime user if
you don't have Amazon Prime no problem
no sweat you can still go to Twitch and
follow us there it helps us out and I
want to thank everyone over this last
couple weeks
who has shown Us big support on Twitch
because of this and it's it's been
tremendous and it's really cool honestly
I I think this is one of the easiest
ways for a creator
to make a living because it doesn't cost
the the prime subscriber anything it
doesn't cost us anything and we get a we
get a few bucks from each person who
subscribes every month it's really cool
it's kind of a cool way
um you know there's a lot of things that
are bad about Amazon
to be frank
um but as far as on Twitch with Amazon
owning twitch because Amazon does own
twitch
um but that that's kind of a cool way to
help creators keep creating
um and help us keep streaming over on
Twitch and streaming in general so thank
you for all your support and we I I I
you know it's it's something I
appreciate that Amazon and twitch does
because it allows you to help support
your favorite streamer or Creator or
podcaster whatever you want to call it
over on Twitch it's really cool so
everyone stick around
we're gonna bring bonehead of the week
up Gabe's got a heart out so we may have
to go fast on it everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
we're gonna get the phone here we
possibly can when Gabe Sanchez gets on
here
hey he's got a heart out today
but I got a couple of videos I want to
show you in the meantime I don't know
have you guys heard about the Ed Sheeran
um thing with Marvin Gaye I didn't I
haven't spoke a lot about this on the
show
um I've spoke about it with the people I
know in private but I'm I'm happy that
Ed Sheeran won his case I think it's
good for the artist I think it's good
for music I think it's good for the
music industry
um not just because Ed Sheeran
threatened to uh to retire if he would
lose this case uh but I I believe that
all art is inspired
um we live in a time in an age where
there's so much history of Art in front
of us and there's been a lot of Art and
history in front of us and uh Ed Sheeran
yesterday won his case in court against
the Marvin Gaye estate and his and
Marvin Gaye's executors I actually
believe if Marvin Gaye was right I don't
know that he'd bring this case maybe I'm
wrong but
um and really honestly I believe that
this this case what what the slippery
slope was here if you're not aware of
this is Marvin Gaye a state there are
executors were alleging that one of
Ed Sheeran's songs was exactly the same
um and they and he stole from them and
they were trying to gain the ownership
of that song in court they did not
achieve that and I believe that if they
would have then it would be a slippery
slope to Big Money buying huge catalogs
of music right
um and here's here's here's what I
believe
um is it was at stake and I think this
is why I'm I'm so excited and again not
because I'm a huge Ed Sheeran fan or I
think Marvin Gaye can go [__] himself I
I don't believe either of those things
have to be true for you to see this and
what what I saw happening is if if the
estate would win what could happen is
big money could buy huge catalogs of
music
the sad part about that is then they
could level challenges to any new music
any new hot charting music out there
they could [__] they could [__]
level any Challenge and there would be
no one owning new music it would only be
big money owning big huge catalogs and
it would it would stop people from
writing music
as much we wouldn't have new music
and we would get weird stuff because
people would be trying to absolutely
change every single sound
and and that's and that is and I'm I'm
telling you
um I'm happy and I don't care what
artist it was
um and to be frank with you I wish I
wish Robin Thicke who I'm not a big fan
of that I mean no I mean I like that
song
um that Marvin Gaye won that case I just
wish they would have had as good a legal
defense
because if you listen to these songs if
you listen to them separately it's hard
to tell I mean unless you're really
[__] trained at this step but it's
hard to tell and the only time you can
really tell is when they're played on
top of each other
so but I do think that it's kind of
um it's kind of gross that in both these
cases Robin thicken Ed Sheeran it was
Marvin Gaye's executors who brought this
case not Marvin Gaye himself he's dead
he's dead the owners of the music and
that is the most important key here to
Ed Sheeran winning this case
am I saying that right Sheeran Sharon I
don't know
he's a great artist I think Ed's great
um he knows music really well he did a
great job from what I could tell reading
about the court case he did a great job
making his case in court
um and and it went his way here here's
uh here's a clip from his press
conference
um after he won his case let's listen in
just a bit I know this doesn't have to
do with politics but folks this has a
lot to do with with music in your life I
know it may not seem like it but this
was an important case this may have been
a turning point into how much money was
going to influence artists writing new
music let's listen
but at the same time I'm unbelievably
frustrated that racist pains like this
are allowed to go to court at all
spent the last eight years talking about
two songs with dramatically Different
lyrics Melodies and four chords which
are also different and used by
songwriters every day all over the world
these chords are common building blocks
which we use to create music long before
Let's Get It On was written and will be
used to make music long after we are all
gone they are in a songwriters alphabet
our toolkit and should be there for all
of us to use no one owns them all the
way they are played in the same way that
nobody owns the color blue so that's a
little bit from the press conference
again or whether you're a fan of Ed or
not
um he said it's an eight Line Court
battle eight year long Court battle over
a couple chords that may sound the same
in the same order and and really
um I I think I think music was saved for
this for this for this court case and if
you're a music lover which I know a lot
of you in my audience are I'm a big
music lover I I I'm a huge fan uh Prime
country as it's called the country from
the 1980s and 19 these my fans know
that's one of my favorite
um genres of music and it's because I
like to sing it
but the thing is is that we shouldn't
discount any any art or any music uh no
matter no matter what it is because it's
an expression of us it's expression
expression of our Humanity it's an
expression of our experience
um and I think I think it's a great it's
a great win in the court and it's a
great win for freedom and liberty in
this country and I know that sounds
crazy but it truly is that we have the
freedom and liberty to express ourselves
even with inspiration from others and
from the past
um and and we can get inspired whether
it be in music whether it be in painting
or whether it be in our politics by the
past and show that hey our inspiration
comes from the people who came before us
and we will not forget what came before
us to make sure to make sure
that we protect what is in the future so
um Ed I I I'm glad he fought this battle
and I'm glad that he did this
um it is a big win for art speaking of
that speaking of art um the uh
uh the writer strike goes on in in
California we played a a couple videos
of Adam Conover uh he's a huge fighter
uh in this battle and he's and what he's
really trying to do is make sure that
the word gets out of exactly what this
is and another guy rather you agree or
disagree with him uh uh Hassan the Hun
on Twitter uh sanabi or san [__]
um that he's known as uh he's a twitch
streamer he's also a political
commentator I disagree with Hassan on a
regular basis I actually full disclosure
uh you twitchies are out there will know
that I actually raid whatever that means
I really don't honestly know what it
means I'll raid his room and raid his
waiting rooms A lot of times because I
want you to go listen to Hassan Hassan
um he streams like eight hours a day
it's [__] Insanity I mean I I stream
two hours
does it different right I taught for two
[__] hours straight front to back
there's not much of me I don't I mean
sometimes I gotta get up and go pee a
lot of times you guys don't even know
that I do that
I do it in a way that you don't even
know you didn't know that but yeah it
happens I'm trying to create something
that seems very similar to talk radio
now Hassan's different he's he's a
streamer he's doing something totally
different it's totally different kind of
way of doing it but he doesn't like
eight hours a day and yesterday he
really did help out the cause there
um which I want to thank Adam and Hassan
for helping out the cause no matter what
our differences are
um in our in our views and how far we
would go with uh some of our some of our
politics but I want to thank them just
like Adam thanked Hassan here he said
thank you Hassan for streaming from the
picket line all day and helping us shut
down the Marvel production solidarity in
action and and for you for those of you
out there
who love art the same way if you were
cheering on the decision of Ed Sheeran
the songwriter of writing a song you
should be you should be standing in
solidarity uh with the writers in
Hollywood because they're the ones who
bring you the content that you love the
writers are the ones that really do
create the things that you see these
actors say most times the actors have
their lines written for them we watched
a video from uh Rob Lowe yesterday that
said hey all the great lines that I have
all the great scenes that I act out
they're written and they're written by
writers and we should stand in
solidarity with them in that in that
achievement of art because that's
exactly what it is whether it's drama or
comedy and we should definitely stand in
solidarity with them and they're they're
um I I think I think everyone can get
around workers in this country it's a
cause that we can on all coalesce around
um so I think Adam Adam and Hassan using
their platforms uh to bring to bring a
attention to the writers strike there in
Los Angeles is very very very important
so so um thank you to both of them even
though I I don't we operate our show
here because there is no writer
it's just it's just me running my mouth
so if we did have writers we may not
have parts of the show
[Laughter]
um
oh man so waiting on Gabe Sanchez we're
gonna do um bonehead of the week there's
another video I want to show you though
in the meantime and uh speaking of bone
net of the week this this [__]
is the reason why we have an alpha cook
on this is this is the truth this is the
reason why we have the alpha cuck
um designation on bonehead of the week
and you're gonna
you're gonna find out exactly why uh
Patriot takes keeps tabs Patriot takes
on Twitter keeps tabs on this idiot now
um Ethan Schmidt is a Kerry Lake and
Trump simp right huge Trump simp he's
also a [__] absolute Nazi the the
this kid runs around and you'll go in
like Target he'll go in PetSmart he'll
go in a bunch of retail stores in
Arizona that's where he's at and he and
he he goes in if there's a pride flag or
any kind of rainbows at all it triggers
him triggers him hard he's terrified of
rainbows I mean absolutely terrified of
it actually it's all fake he's just he's
just faking it he's making up [__]
on the internet and he's making it up to
get clout
and I'm gonna give them a little bit of
air time today but I think it's
hilarious and the reason why I think
it's hilarious is the reason why we have
the alpha cuck
category in bone net of the week you're
gonna see why this oh my God you talk
about a [__] cuck this is hilarious
so Patriot dicks finds this video on
this Ethan Schmidt posted this video
someone didn't like steal this from him
out of his phone this he posted this
[__] okay
yeah you can already tell that this
guy's gonna be a [__] box right with
this half-assed beard he's trying to go
with the mustache
the the the the the [__] collared
shirt what the [__] is this but listen
to this guy listen to what he thinks
women should do for him this is
hilarious
look
if I don't have a hundred TP USA girls
lined up begging me to impregnate them
what
what for you you folks out there who
don't know what TP USA is what he's
referring to
is turning points USA so Ethan here
Ethan here thinks that there should be a
hundred at least
TP USA Women lined up ready for him to
impregnate them
[Laughter]
I'm sorry again over the left I I can't
I can't stop uh someone points out here
yeah like like Robbie points out here
their Heist most of these turning points
USA chicks that he's talking about like
the ones that go to the youth
organizations are like high school and
young college girls that's who he's
talking about
what the [__]
it it gets it gets better let's listen
the next year next year our country has
no hope no no future um oh really
sure
I'm the most eligible bachelor in
America if my genes don't
ah he's the most eligible bachelor in
the country a Ethan I don't know if you
know what that means but normally I'm
just gonna throw this out there
normally I would say that
um
most women no matter what their
viewpoints are turning points USA or not
are not going to be lined up around the
block to be impregnated by someone with
a beard like this okay listen I I know
it takes a long time in your life to
achieve the beauty like I have I
understand the beard beauty that I have
I get it Ethan and not everyone
is created with the ability until
they're older to maybe grow a beard like
I have
but you my friend not only
have a shitty beard you have less
desirable of a [__] brain and
thoughts
so I don't know if it's the beard or if
it's actually that you think you're the
most eligible bachelor in the country
but let's continue with his little
delusion here you pass on you know this
country is going to go downhill real
quick you got all these dummies you know
having babies you know we have and we
need to start pumping out these
Christian nationalists these white
Christian Ultra nationalist babies if we
want a future
Ethan is a Nazi now it makes sense hmm
now it makes sense but you know
oh my god dude listen I I don't really
know if Ethan believes all this stuff
he's just posting stupid social media
videos online
but the reason why
the reason why women don't want to [__]
you Ethan is because of your stupid
[__] videos online man
so I mean if you want if you want to
attract
woman or anyone really for that matter I
don't care it doesn't make me any
difference man woman whoever you want to
attract if you want a loved one and
significant other maybe they will or
won't [__] you Ethan you should probably
rethink the videos that you're making
and the videos that you're posting
online for crying out loud but why is
this important you say why is this
important listen folks this is political
discourse
he is is as stupid as this sounds and as
cocky as this sounds because it is cuck
at best
this this [__] [__] box
is a Kerry lake and a Donald Trump
supporter and he is online getting his
tens of thousands of followers to
believe
that he is the most eligible bachelor in
the United States
and that the only way going forward is
for him to impregnate white women so
they can create white Christian
nationalists and as a matter of fact if
he's impregnating 100 women
does that make him Christian I mean it
doesn't sound too Christian to me I
thought it was man and a woman to most
white Christian nationalists it wasn't a
man and a hundred women or is it
I wonder I wonder if this is where
they're going I wonder if this is who
people who are setting policy and laws
are placating to like I don't know Kerry
Lake when he she would she would he
would go on the campaign trail with
Kerry Lake folks
he isn't just some dummy
with a [__] camera phone posting [__]
on Instagram and Tick Tock this
[__] was following around Kerry
Lake taking pictures with her
she was proud to have him as a supporter
for her campaign I wonder I wonder what
it could be why Kerry Lake lost huge
in Arizona could anyone figure that out
why it is that Kerry Lake lost huge I
wonder what it could be maybe it had to
do with this [__] fool
what do you think maybe maybe just maybe
it had something to do with him
it could be
that it was Ethan
who knows who knows
I guess we'll find out
in a moment uh Escape Sanchez joining us
where is he he's kind of hard out I'm
trying to
I'm trying to get him in here sorry
about that sorry about that little delay
there I'm trying to get make sure
because he's kind of hard out today man
me you know what a hard out is
it means he can't go past a certain
point
so we only have a certain amount of time
to do um to do bonehead of the week but
that
fast stories do we have can I fill time
until we get the Gabe Sanchez on because
we got some content we want to we want
to show you
on um
uh on Jeannie Thomas and kellyanne
Conway that's going to be the majority
of it what is this Howard Stern thing I
couldn't figure this out this morning
apparently Howard Stern went to a Knicks
game Nick's game is that what it was
and the the players didn't know who he
was or something
is it is that what it is
I I can't really figure it out this
morning
I I don't know why why why would the NBA
players have to know who Howard Stern is
to be quite honest
I mean Howard Stern hasn't been on
public radio like like the Airways for a
long time I mean he's on he's on uh he's
on Sirius XM but that's all gated [__]
right like Howard yet to pay to listen
to Howard
so why why would anyone know exactly who
he is if it's been damn near I think
it's been 20 years hasn't it
when's the last time he was on
like FM radio
I I don't I don't know I don't know when
the last time he was syndicated on FM on
FM radio but it's got to be at least 20
years so why would a bunch of people in
their 20s
know exactly who Howard Stern is
I mean some of them I'm sure do
but I mean he's not like in their daily
discourse
I don't understand it
I mean he interviews a lot of
celebrities
but that that doesn't mean that people
in their 20s especially athletes would
know exactly who [__] Howard Stern is
and I guess he was upset or some [__]
which hey I I'm gonna agree with Howard
when I agree with him but dude
this this is why this is why celebrities
get a bad [__] rap
right this is the stupid [__]
but maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm off my
rocker about this Howard Stern thing
what do you think Gabe's inches did you
see the Howard Stern story here he is no
hey he's rushing to get to the uh the
broadcast I know I know sorry I was on
the I was on the call with the client so
I was like I gotta go all right yeah
yeah yeah client client he's trying to
promote that only fans page that he's
got well look I mean like people are
into certain things and I gotta there's
a market to fill okay and right well you
know it happens the Howard Stern thing
is I guess he went to a Knicks game and
the players didn't know who he was and
he's a little mad that they didn't know
who he was oh and I'm like I'm like what
do they think he was no they they didn't
know who he was why would they know but
Howard Stern hasn't been on FM radio for
like 20 years and these people are in
their 20s most of them so why would they
know what he is really honestly this is
like the moment you know the meme uh
with Steve Buscemi on Saturday live and
like yo kids
that was from Community always like okay
yeah yeah it was uh hello uh hello my
hip my hip no it was hello my fellow
[__] a I don't know it's funny though
I think it's hello my fellow kids how do
you do fellow kids yeah it was you it
was 30 Rock sorry it was 30. okay okay
yeah yeah it's a famous Meme and and
Steve Buscemi is here oh you know what
we're talking about it so much we just
might as well show it okay if you got a
link on Twitter send it to me we'll play
it and then we'll go to bonehead of the
week how much time do you have when is
your heart out is it the bottom of the
hour or the top no it's 10 it's 10 30.
oh God damn dude we gotta rush through
it man okay well give me this [__]
Steve Buscemi video and then we'll go to
bonan okay all right all right we're
gonna play that YouTube It's a YouTube
video oh okay all right well nope that's
the URL ah okay uh no we're going to
Bone end of the week here we go no I got
it I got it I got it I got it I got it
no I got it I got it this [__]
gets way too excited about [__] and when
he finds something he's like no we gotta
do this we gotta do this you're the one
who asked me I was talking about it I
was talking about the picket line
um earlier yeah yeah we were talking I
thought you were talking about doing it
for the show that's why well no no I
mean we can play playing on the show
yeah yeah I was like Hey that would make
great interview for like what was that
if you if you did that right I gotta I
have to wait because they they uh they
only have the times up until today and
each so for context Tony was like hey
you should go down to the picket line
and go interview some people and I was
like yeah yeah but I I can't do it today
obviously because I'm leaving but uh I
can do it next week but also I didn't
know this until I looked it up there
were specific hours based on where they
are I do have well I have ADHD all right
see I put it up on the screen he can't
help himself yeah yeah I can't help it I
gotta I gotta I gotta say it's I do have
ADHD uh I don't take medication anymore
but I have been thinking about maybe
taking it again
please don't yeah please don't we don't
want you to change uh you like so so we
like your your your your imperfections
thank you thank you I'm perfectly
imperfect as I said as my mother says I
guess right uh but yeah there's specific
times that they show up to be at certain
Studios during the day so well yeah
because you're trying because they're
trying to stop some of these Teamster
tracks
yesterday were successful at stopping um
I think it's a Marvel movie yeah it's
Marvel I for well I don't know the
series I think it's a Marvel series that
they're shooting I don't know they were
going to do some shooting yesterday and
they kind of stopped it I don't know
what they were filming and I I showed
Adam Conover and Hassan um right right
blocking it are they blocked it let's
show this uh Buscemi and then we'll go
to bonehead of the week let's show this
here I'm Mr done again and you caught
the guy who did it good for you oh no
man uh Tracy is helping me with this but
I could see how you went there I have a
criminal skull shape I don't I don't
think there's a [__] I don't think this
is it is it not that's why we're friends
we have
isn't it a flashback it's that one right
there it is right here okay here it is
here it is
[Music]
how do you do fellow kids what so I'm
glad you called him
it's yeah I mean charity of what gave
Sanchez's ADHD had yeah yeah how do you
do fellow kids I got a skateboard on my
desk I could have done this whole thing
if I if I had known this was gonna be
the bit yeah you know what's funny you
know what's funny is I like wearing a
backwards hat because I grew up in the
90s so I like right yeah yeah yeah and
people like you really wear your hat
backwards I'm like yeah I grew up in the
[__] 90s product of the 90s man what
are you supposed how everyone everyone
dude Saved by the Bell uh Fresh Prince
like all of these shows even cartoons
all backwards hat kids listen I got the
other day because I love hats and I got
a brand new
um uh Jumpman Air Jordan white hat white
hat with the black Jump Man on the front
right when I was in junior high I had a
black one with a red Bill and a red
Jumpman and then the strap the Snapback
was red and I wore it so much that this
the the strap broke in half and I had to
go find red electrical tape to tape the
strap so I could still wear the hat I
mean it was like the red bear I wore it
every [__] day backwards so that was
my thing there's one thing I want to
bring up uh so today is
Cinco de Mayo yes it is
but I also wanted to because I have a I
have a I have a patron uh on my patreon
yeah and
um I told him I would do this on Monday
but I was like oh I should do it on
Tuesday but then Tuesday you know
whatever anyway I feel like Friday is
the appropriate time to do this since
it's Cinco de Mayo since in Cinco de
Mayo okay so
um he sent me some photos and I wanted
to share he's part of the [__] fam
and the main reason was because they're
all wearing [__] hats oh
so uh well God damn well get you know
it's just one of those things
um anyway so hello to all my fellow my
fellow kids
uh uh so yeah I wanted to uh I wanted to
bring those up so this is the this is
the group the [__] fam right here
nice Lids by the way I know those are
pretty good pretty good if you ask me
you know uh and then there's that one
and then
um
[Music]
you know I just gotta I'm getting
[__] hungry now God damn it when we
still got an hour to go and we've only
got 30 minutes with Gabe Sanchez so
everyone stick around don't go anywhere
right after this bonehead of the
[__] week we'll be right back
with bonehead of the week
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show happy
Cinco de Mayo to the welcome van
everyone's talking about my slim jim
tacos listen I know you remember when I
ate this onion tacos your wife out there
the Texas Ball but I don't make tacos
with Slim Jims okay I was just a bit for
here on the show and they were [__]
nasty I said at the time I should have
dined that they were good it was gross
as [__] yeah it was [__] Texas he was
like oh no it tasted great I'm like yeah
as soon as I got off the show I text
Texas Paul like the minute son of a
[__] I did I think you were in the
[__] jet I was like you [__]
that was the nastiest thing ever you
know what I sat here perfectly fine no
tummy ache because I didn't do that what
[__] white white Taco ass
oh I see how it is that white Christian
nationalist tacos Slim Jim and cheese I
mean those are the types of tacos that
Ethan Schmidt Alpha cook would wear I
mean I played the the clip did you have
you seen it oh yeah yeah yeah that's
right most eligible bachelor in the
United States or in America
also which I just want to point out how
ridiculous is that he's like I want a
hundred women lined up so I can
impregnate them okay one you'd be
[__] lucky
no no no no
and also uh the idea that he's like I'm
gonna impregnate all these women okay so
you're gonna financially support all of
these women wow that's what you're gonna
no that's not what he's saying of course
he's a dead guy I know I know but I also
want to know like where like is he is he
on assistance is he living in his mom's
basement eating toastino rolls like what
is he doing right like I'm I'm sure I
actually I I would almost bet he's a
paid operative I bet there's dark money
there's probably money that's paying him
uh very least crazy things speaking of
dark money we got bone and leak let's go
to Bonet of the week the bonehead of the
dark money week
Wednesday s
[Music]
[Applause]
what's funny about saying bonehead of
the dark money of the week is that all
three of these [__] at some
point have been offered dark money uh
especially the one in the middle holy
[__] we found that out this morning but
let's start with Stephen Crowder
um Gabe Sanchez why is Stephen Crowder
on the bone of the week is it because he
shows his testicles or is it because he
wants to try to make it to where his
wife can't divorce him or is it because
we we realize that he's just the dumb
son of a [__] that we've always thought
he is I mean it's a you know it's like
that girl you know in the theme of Cinco
de Mayo it's like like it's the girls
like why can't we have both right and
it's it really all the all of the above
it's all the above it's a it's a guy
who's a [__] [__] he's an abusive
husband he's a liar and he's just like
uh he's he's also not not only abusive
husband but he's also an abusive uh boss
right and we saw that
on the show when he was like oh man I
hear some more comedy I'm gonna lean
into this and it's like man that was
incredibly cringe-worthy and it doesn't
help you out at all uh but yeah it's
like all of the above right it's it's
him showing his genitals to his staff
members as him being abusive verbally
and emotionally to his wife who was
pregnant at the time which I'm sure that
he was you know it's not just that
moment I'm sure he's been abusive before
that and now he's been a bonehead a lot
and he plays he plays the the victim to
say oh everyone's attacking me and
Candace Owens is coming after me and and
talking about think it's like shut the
[__] up man [__] Hey listen I've
gotta get I got a great clip of Stephen
Crowder it's not this week but this clip
really really encompasses everything you
just said about him where he [__]
around and he finds out and then he gets
his ass kicked and he acts like he's the
victim afterwards because he instigated
it here he is trying to [__] with a
bunch of union workers and watch what
happens to Stephen Crowder he's the one
in the the leather jacket here with the
nice hair let's watch
bro
oh
my God
that's the story of Stephen Crowder
right there look you you
see a Nazi you hit him okay now I mean
it happens when when a Nazi throws a
punch at you you throw exactly yeah
sometimes is how it works when you're
defending yourself okay so and also
Stephen Crowder you know manipulating by
editing the footage to show I'm the
victim but when you really play it out
and then you're like oh actually Steven
Crowder
who threw hands first right well that's
how it happens okay speaking of throwing
hands first let's go to Tucker Carlson
um Fox Carlson Fox News is totally
dumping on this [__] because
that's your suspicion right the fox I
believe yeah but I believe what's I I
believe what's happening is uh Fox News
is releasing these clips right so last
week we heard that there was a text
message that like sounded the alarms at
Fox News have been like oh [__] we can't
have this on the eve of the Dominion
settlement right and so you look at the
things that are happening it doesn't
seem to me that it would be Tucker or
his producer now these aren't terrible
things that have been shown own and
these videos but they allude to his type
of behavior right I wouldn't be
surprised if as these things trickle out
right because you're trying to you know
Tucker Carlson makes a video a week and
a half ago I think and he says you know
it's the corporate media and they're
trying to silence you and they're the
ones telling lies
and truth will prevail and those who are
like myself who are true tellers we will
become stronger
and people who are lying like corporate
media they will uh become small right
and so
um
that was a it was like a very like I'm
not going to say fox's name but I'm
gonna throw some shade their way and fox
was like okay Bet and they start
dripping this video footage out to Media
Matters and they've been slowly doing
one by one I mean there was one on
Monday or Tuesday and they released one
and then Wednesday they were like three
videos and then Thursday there were
another couple videos that came like I
think here's one right here yesterday
this yeah this is the one talking about
uh pillow fights women in pillow fights
in the bathroom let's listen ask you a
question you don't have to answer it's
personal I'm not speaking of you but
more in general of ladies when they go
to the ladies room and Paragon knows is
there actually nose pattern going on
sometimes oh
the sound of that
most of the time is lipstick
do pillow fights ever break out you
don't have to not in the back okay
that'd be more a dorm actually oh my God
so you are such a good sport such a good
person thank you like inherently these
videos I know you do but you do not
deserve that and I mean it with great
affection I got you man
he's such a dumb [__] man see the thing
is like these videos they're not
terrible right right they're not like oh
my God this is damning well even Matt
Walsh is coming to his defense like oh
so we're supposed to we're so we're
supposed to believe that that this is
bad because Tucker Carlson is a passive
aggressive misogynist like walking what
what I what I do see like it's I will
say this the text message that got
leaked this week that was like Hey here
we went over that right right and it and
and I wouldn't be surprised if more
stuff comes out this week or this
weekend or up uh next week as a means of
Fox News Santa Tucker if you want to
challenge us challenge us then we will
uh continue to release this and I think
this is as a as a means of like look
We're Not Gonna We're Not Gonna Bluff
here we're gonna actually release some
[__] and it probably won't be the worst
on video yet right because my suspicion
and I could be totally wrong on this but
my suspicion is that they're slowly
leaking these videos out and as you look
at right wing you know media online and
other Talking Heads online they're
saying oh well these aren't bad they're
not terrible blah blah blah blah all
this stuff about how these videos don't
show anything that's the worst you guys
have oh come on
and what I think is happening
is that fox is releasing these videos
that aren't terrible right and they're
getting people on the right to align
with them and say oh yeah yeah we stand
with Tucker we stand with Tucker uh
these aren't terrible things right and
then bury him and then there potentially
is this uh
I I'm assuming from all the hours and
all the years that he's been on the show
he said even worse things that they have
recorded on tape and they probably have
a [__] intern going through those
papers right the the the uh the
deposition papers and also like
Discovery and stuff and going through
and being like got it we gotta flag this
flag this flag this and we want to
release it and I think what's gonna
happen is that these are warning shots
they're not bad they say oh okay he's a
little bit creepy but it's not a
terrible thing that's like oh this is
the thing that's going to totally ruin
your career but I think what will happen
is they're getting people to back these
positions to say oh Tucker's not bad
that's that's the worst you guys got oh
come on I still back I still back Tucker
Carlson I stand with him and then they
release the serious [__] and then you
have to see where people line up the
people that aligned with him to say we
stand with Tucker will they continue to
stand with Tucker I wouldn't be
surprised if they did
but I wouldn't be surprised also if
that's the
the strategy they're having right now
well I actually think there's something
uh more at play here I think Tucker
Carlson
um is actually planning I think this is
this is why Fox News is doing what
you're saying is because there's a
there's a deeper reason why they're
doing it is because Tucker Carlson is
gonna release his own platform at that
same exact time to try to attract his
audience to his platform and to [__] Fox
News I think is what fox is scared of
and what fox is trying to do is bang him
up so his audience does not follow him
and the reason why is because there's
this weird thing that happened this week
and I know this isn't proof that Tucker
talks to Alex about this but this is
very interesting that Alex Jones was
pranked
um by a phone call this week he's
talking about it in this clip uh he
thought it was Tucker but listen to one
part of this I want you to I want you to
follow me on this listen
one of the most bizarre things that ever
happened to me in my life happened
yesterday afternoon at about 5 45. the
most bizarre thing in his life okay this
is weird in the beginning but let's
listen to what the bizarre thing was I'm
sitting in an accounting meeting
Infowars accounting meeting yeah because
they owe [__] loads of money and they're
trying to hide it here yeah and the
phone rings uh-huh and it says Tucker
Carlson so he looks at his cell phone
gave Sanchez and it says Tucker Carlson
is calling and we talked go here and
there on the phone we text a lot oh
really oh really hmm see this is the
part that I think is most interesting
because Alex Jones
um has created this huge Empire with
Independent Media and I think Tucker
Carlson would love to do the same thing
so why wouldn't you go to Alex Jones to
figure out exactly even though even
though I mean logistically speaking and
also financially it's not smart to do
and also would take you a long time to
do unless you join a platform or you
acquire a service right and start your
own but wow
but that's what that's what I yeah it's
dumb as [__] to start from scratch like
we do
but that's but that's but that's what
that's what I think Tucker is is more
apt to do because as Tucker Carlson is
an ego Maniac he believes his fans will
follow him now you can watch this Alex
Jones video and continue this I think in
this context this is what is relevant
but what's funny is is Alex Jones
realizes he's being pranked and he calls
Tucker at that point
um so these two Alex Jones and Dr
Carlson are really close friends and if
that shouldn't have been [__] alarm
bells to Fox News or anyone who took
Tucker Carlson seriously then you should
have your [__] head checked
um so that's why one reason when I stop
um listening to Joe Rogan a lot because
I used to listen when he had comedians
on but yeah we stopped listening to him
when I realized that this that that
Tucker excuse me
Joe Rogan was close to Alex Jones just
like everyone else should be like
[__] alarm Bells when they know that
Tucker Carlson is good buddies with Alex
Jones I mean this is not hard to
understand so you know birds of a
feather well it is true well speaking of
birds of the feather I'm glad you said
that let's go back to Bone end of the
week Justice Clarence Thomas is at the
top of the page but our d him and Alpha
guck this week are birds of the feather
the alpha [__] is his wife Jeannie
Thomas and then the dishonorable mention
is Kelly and Conway now
[Music]
who needs a soundboard when you get the
mouse sound effects okay
okay let's let's talk about the news
this morning because this was not our
plan when we put Clarence Thomas on no
um it's all [__] connected man well
just like you said it's getting worse
and worse and worse for Clarence Thomas
and we find out this morning that Leo
Leonard uh uh a a a conservative
activist who had a who had a court case
for his non-profit in front of the
Supreme Court to tear down parts of the
Voting Rights Act in a 5-4 decision that
Clarence Thomas voted on
was funnel money alien Conway two
Clarence Thomas's wife how did Clarence
Thomas vote in favor or not in favor
well that's kind of funny because it
would almost seem like he voted the way
that Leo Leonard's money wanted him to
vote it really seems that way I don't
know maybe I'm wrong maybe maybe I'm
just out of my [__] mind but it does
you know what's funny and I said this in
the first 30 minutes of the show and if
you haven't missed it and you go back
and List It
is that people on the right and the
haters in the chat they're like oh
Democrat to Crypt Turner Madden's laptop
let's deep State this deep state that
like what the [__] do you think this is
man yeah what do you what do you think
like do you not think that this is the
Deep State the people who decide the
laws of the land to determine the
presence that is set before are given
money to their spouses to make those
decisions
that the rich Elites that are in power
and in control public and Rich Elites
this is not the Deep State this is not
the swamp the very swamp that Donald
Trump had in his very own cabinet right
they had his advisors
you know what's funny about that you say
that Kelly and Conway was vehemently
against Donald Trump until money started
leaking into her pocket to be pulled
down and then I was surprised that
George Conway stayed married to her for
as long as they did and it only recently
did he finally have some sort of
epiphany moment and say okay wow you
know I know a lot of people like George
Conway but I've got a lot of opinions
about George Connor oh no I'm not really
[__] convenient for him to be
anti-trump oh yeah yeah listen hey if
you can hate on me for this then hate on
me [__] George Conway as far as 100
[__] 100 if he doesn't like it he can
come on the show and I'll [__] talk
to him about it because that guy that
guy is grifting off the anti-trump
[__] just like kellyanne Conway went
and drifted up Trump support and they
were doing it and making the Griff bet
best for their household on both ends
just because they ended up in a divorce
because they're both scumbags doesn't
impress me oh no not at all yeah
I mean all of these people and you know
when you look at the Supreme Court and
you determine what group is actually
making these suggestions and vetting
these people to put them in power I
don't know it's almost like there's a
certain group by the name of the federal
Society that's the people like George
Conway kellyanne Conway all of these
[__] that are part of it right all of
all of these judges that have been
nominated as like uh as a soft
suggestion but really it's like put this
person in nominate this person make sure
this person's you know put into this
position that's how this rolls if it's
like if we want to talk about the
[__] deep State let's talk about the
federal society and let's talk about the
dark money that flows through that
organization and into politics to
determine who gets what position in this
country exactly specifically within the
Republican party but holy [__] man the
idea that these people and the
Republicans on the Republican side in
the in the party can just look away and
be like
uh no one on the Republican on the right
is of a of a corrupt deep State dark
money background oh no no it's only the
people on the left it's only the people
that are supporting democracy it's only
the people that want Fair elections it's
only the people that want equity and
equality right not the people that are
actually putting money into these people
into these organizations into these
things
I have my own beef with Lincoln project
the Lincoln project steals my [__]
Paparazzi says and [__] those guys from
Lincoln project too dude they've sold
multiple videos they took our [__]
the the bonehead Madness yeah they
[__] stolen and then guess what they
did it for one year and they didn't do
it again this year yeah well it didn't
work very well yeah so it didn't even
work well for our audience and we
probably won't do it next year because
it it's hard to get people to pay
attention to that many polls I think I
mean it was a challenge don't you think
it was a challenge I mean a lot everyone
loves the bonehead of the weak pole
because we do it every week at the same
time well next week it's not bonehead
Madness it's Marge Madness so who knows
maybe maybe we'll get a pay attention
yeah people will get people to pay
attention maybe next year because it's
March Madness maybe next year we'll just
change it all together it'll just be
something totally different yeah yeah we
don't have to do it the same and we get
to do whatever the [__] we want we we
are the people that ride our own fate I
no no actually you decide the bone end
of the weak pole and Paparazzi you're
right [__] those guys at Lincoln project
too
um a lot of people let's listen I might
have a lot of unpopular opinions but I
don't think telling George Conway to go
to hell is is
go [__] here's here's why because
they're all gaslighters and here is his
I soon to be ex-wife I don't think
they're actually finally divorced I
don't think it's official so his
soon-to-be ex-wife maybe his ex-wife now
I'm not really sure the the uh their
marital status at this point
um but here's his soon to be RX why
kellyanne Conway gaslighting America on
Fox news this morning and lying to
everyone listen to this [__] but the
Washington Post this morning then has
this if you could pull it up for it says
judicial activist directed fees to
Clarence Thomas wife and urge no mention
of Ginny Thomas and that Leonard Leo
told you Republican pollster killing
Conway to build the nonprofit then use
the money to pay the spouse of the
Supreme Court just says but not put her
name in it I love how she just breezes
through it right yeah she's like and but
she also has she says it with a smile
like we're really gonna believe this
type of reporting right oh my God it's
the Washington if that's the case and
here's the thing with these reports as
they come out if there was any lie to
them because again you have to make sure
that you're I mean you are you are
defaming someone's name here by saying
that they were involved in taking dark
money influencing the politics or the
decision of the court I mean those are
pretty serious accusations so you would
assume that if they made these things
and the Republican party did did not
agree with them and they said oh this is
all live is all lie right especially
having kellyanne Conway that they'd be
like Oh I'm gonna sue your publication
for for for making the the accusation
that I was at all involved in this but
they're not going to because they were
involved in this and they're going to
try and play it down and be like it's
not actually as bad as you guys think it
is right well and she breathes through
it because here's what happened Leo
Leonard's non-profit was trying to ledge
a court decision at the Supreme Court to
strike down parts of the Voting Rights
Act that's one thing that [__]
someone called her propaganda Barbie I
don't know if you're calling the host or
kellyanne Conway but either way it's
propaganda Barbie on either side of the
[__] table over there at this
interview but here's the thing is that
she breezes over the fact that Leo
Leonard's non-profit had a decision
before The Supreme Court not not for
some weird thing it's to strike down
parts of the Voting Rights Act
which is directly challenging people's
right to vote and and oppressing people
to vote you [__] he was trying
to make sure that in in in red states
and southern states that they did not
have to seek The Authority that was
written in law to make sure that they
were not suppressing and oppressing
people of color and minorities right to
vote in the South because I don't know
history like modern [__] history I
don't know people were alive during
Civil Rights but there's a lot of them
still Jesus [__] crisis isn't ancient
history this was just in the last second
half of the century you [__]
but here's the thing is that Leo Leonard
had a case before The Supreme Court and
he paid kellyanne Conway to pay Genie
Thomas who is Clarence Thomas's wife
paid his household directly and Kelly
and Conway frames it up like this this
[__] [__] I'll say it and [__]
[__]
I'll give you a chance to respond to
that oh yeah give her a [__] chance
this morning yeah other networks are
telling the truth yeah clearly I didn't
watch any of that oh clearly you didn't
watch the truth
according to the Washington Post
according to the watch tell us when it
was [__] tell us when the [__] it was
according to the Washington Post tell us
when it was you're saying because then
she admits to it listen yeah it's
quoting that article I think it's an
important quote he says I've known the
Thomases they've been my friend since
1990. oh this friendship thing man I
love how vicious and gossipy people oh
wow their privacy yeah and their safety
right I don't want people to know that
I'm paying them money to make decisions
for me at the Supreme Court yeah we know
what the [__] he's doing deliciousness
from 10 years ago 11 years ago oh you
don't you don't know you don't you don't
know vicious [__] you don't know
vicious let me tell you something about
what's coming for you [__] this
country and this pro-democracy Coalition
is going to be damn vicious more vicious
than we've ever been against your
corrupt deep statism you [__]
man I I'm so sick of pieces of [__] like
this gas fighting America and not only
that convincing the people that are like
oh I hate the Deep State deep State this
deep state that deep State this they're
all coming after us oh man they're using
our government against us to take our
right yeah dummy and you're voting for
them
stupid [__] I I just I'm just I just
wanna I don't I wanna I wanna point out
something though yeah so when when when
the pro publica when the first one came
out that said he took these luxury
vacations I said propublica was going to
release I mean well I'm pretty sure that
I said propublica was going to be the
one that dropped the direct payment
right and or like here's money right and
I was wrong I was wrong I was right
about the direct payment coming through
right the closest one I think there's I
think it's still coming to be more of a
direct band I still think there's more
but Washington Post was the one that
broke it for them which was what
happened was we went from luxury
vacations
friends friends hi Kelly and Conway
Leonard Leonard Leo is can you notice
how Harlan Hitler and Leonard Leo it's
all about friendship right yeah yeah
yeah I mean I love the alliteration
though you know right uh but we go from
we go from Harlan Hitler buying luxury
vacations for his friends that he owns
Which is Clarence Thomas and then you
get to oh he just happened to buy the
home of Clarence Thomas right uh his
mother's home and she lives there rent
free no biggie yeah rent there just a
normal average Day friend thing to do
exactly and then I think it was the
Washington Post uh or someone else it
wasn't the propublica but then they
released that Jenny Thomas had taken
money that was not disclosed right and
then you two yesterday yesterday these
both came out yesterday I think
yesterday or the day before was the one
about the 6200 monthly payments to a
private school for the kids right that
was their nephew but technically legally
was their son because they were the
guardian they were the guardian they
were the legal Guardians at that point
and the point in the day I was like oh
yeah this is the closest we'll get in
terms of from propublica and then sure
enough hours later we get this
Washington Post article this report that
says oh actually what happened was uh
Leonard Leo page anytime or paid Killian
Conway to page Jenny Thomas
for what like what was she paying him
for what was she paying for tell me what
else was she wishing for let's listen
listen to what she says I'll let you
tell the lie I'll let her tell the LIE
from her own [__] mouth listen has
turned into violence now where people
are outside of Supreme Court that's a
lie that's a lie trying to assess that's
a lie that's a [__] lie that's a lie
that's a [__] lie that guy who was
who was threatening to kill a judge was
miles away from the home it's a [__]
lie but let's keep going it's not the
only lie she tells people will stop at
nothing they want Clarence Thomas to
resign yes yeah we do yeah great devil
can replace him with one of them yes
that's exactly right okay Jenny Thomas
was one of my contractors and oh really
she's she had worked at the Heritage
Foundation she was part of the
Grassroots okay is part of the
Grassroots she had worked in the Reagan
Administration this is a serious person
who you're not making it sound good I
worked in public policy oh she's a
serious person we're supposed to believe
that the [__] that that cat that excuse
me Genie Thomas was texting Mark Meadows
during during the big lie period uh from
the election until January 6th about a
bunch of Q Anon stuff about gitmo and
hangings and all kinds of crazy ass
queuing on [__] we're supposed to
believe that she's a serious person Gabe
Sanchez yeah she's a serious [__]
joke they're all clowns they're all
idiots I just want to let you know it is
10 29 right now yeah yeah so let's move
on I also have people in the chat that
are like Gabe Gabe Gabe you got to go
you gotta go I know I gotta go I gotta
go okay well let's play the rest of this
clip and uh at the polling I'm gonna
finish
research and data analytics we had no
business before the court but how do you
feel about it no business oh yeah well
no what she's saying is the US is the
polling organization didn't have it yeah
yeah that doesn't
mean that Leonard lito the person making
the payment he had a case alternative
facts that's what it is it's all
alternative facts Kelly and Conway being
like I didn't directly have business but
another person that I contracted with
and did business with did have business
before the court and yeah sure we paid
Jenny Thomas because she was a
contractor not because she's [__]
sharing the same bed as [__] Clarence
Thomas
do you think they share the same bed
I've been there I I don't think I think
they have several I feel like they're
like my grandparents they slept in
separate bedrooms my grandma and grandpa
they after a certain point they're like
look I love you but we need it we need
we need at least 12 [__] between
[__] fart at night and I don't like
the smell of your farts that's how it
works all right let's do this bone of
the week Justice Thomas his wife Jeannie
as the Albuquerque and their money go
between Kelly and Conway as a
dishonorable mention beautiful photo
that is true but let's give the winner
Clarence Thomas his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
oh bone end of the week thank you Gabe
Sanchez for sticking around for the
extra minute or two I know you got a
heart out everyone tell Gabe have a
happy weekend I know I don't know how
drunk he's gonna be it is Cinco de Mayo
so it is definitely we'll see how it's
possible uh everybody stick around after
the song I'll be back with you right
after bone end of the week don't go
anywhere you still have 30 minutes left
we still have 30 minutes don't go
anywhere don't go anywhere 30 minutes
with me see you later Gabe foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week bonehead of the week you had
me back don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere I'm gonna be with you for
another 30 minutes
um that was a quick I think that's the
quickest bonehead of the week we've ever
done is it I don't know I think I think
so it was it was just right at about 30
minutes I think is what it was so don't
go anywhere don't go anywhere don't go
anywhere
I know it's single to my own it's Friday
and you want to go start your
celebration we're not done yet I don't
know what the hell I'm gonna talk about
no seriously I have no idea here's the
reason why is because this morning
um I thought I was gonna have Gabe a
heart out at the top of the hour and you
let me know that he's going to be at a
heart out at the bottom of the hour I'm
like oh [__] get the um get the bonehead
assets going then that way I have them
so when we start we start and then he
threw in this D I actually brought up
Steve Buscemi which is my fault knowing
that Gabe would want to play the the
clip of
yeah everyone
um I I hope Gabe has a great Cinco de
Mayo
um so give him give him your best and
really honestly you should go check out
uh what was that
at what was that show.com that's right
what was that show.com over on patreon
it takes you directly to Gabe's patreon
and you see all the extra there you get
on his patreon for what was that so
while you're on patreon uh you go to my
patreon page that's at patreon.com the
Tony Michaels as well and you can see uh
my patreon there also you can go to the
Tony michaels.com and click the patreon
link there
that was pretty cool the uh the Hat
pictures that we got and the folks that
were um that sent in the Hat pictures
I've had several people send me
their hat pictures and if you did send
them to me and I didn't see them in a DM
it's probably because the social media
site is like hiding it from me and
honestly I'm I'm not that great at going
from social media to social media and
staying on top of my DMs I actually
missed DMS from some of my friends
sometimes or people that I'm trying to
chat with to get on the show
because I get several DMS
um sent to me especially when people are
trying to send me stories and stuff to
look at maybe for the show
um so if I miss those it's not
intentional it's just I got a lot of
them and when I get done with the show
meaning like when I go off air and I get
my edits done and I get it posted and I
get all that stuff done I do take time
for myself that's how I do this every
day as a matter of fact is I take time
for myself during the evening during the
afternoons I try to stay off social
media as much as I possibly can I mean
I've got to keep up with the stories
because I got to know what's going on
because I'm commentating on it so I want
to be correct I want to know exactly and
sometimes I don't get it always right
but 99.9 percent of the time I'm 100
correct
um but I really do I try I try to stay
up with everything so it it's um
it's very it's very
um it's very important to keep your
mental health right and I believe that's
part of the show here I've had a lot of
people tell me that personally and
through messages online that this show
rely allows them to have a cathartic and
they use that word cathartic release
um for the for the [__] outrage and
the anger that they have and just
because of my style of doing it because
it's not always complete rage I mean I
have a lot of rage you guys know I'm
[__] pissed off every day I've been
pissed off today about this and really
honestly it's not surprising the
corruption that's happening with Jeannie
Thomas Clarence Thomas
um and kellyanne Conway and then
bleeding into the Trump world I mean
obviously we know that this corruption
is deep with Republicans we understand
that
um but it just it's infuriating it's
infuriating that the mass of people out
there that are yelling scream about the
Deep state but when they actually see it
live and in action in a report like this
and then these [__] come and
gas slight and lie it really does piss
me off when it's like how don't you see
that that that is exactly what you're
bitching about with the hunter Biden
laptop as if a hunter binds laptop even
exists you stupid [__]
you dumb sons of [__] hey you know
what
let me play let me play part of this
because this is all the while that
[__] Jim Comer and Jim Jordan are out
there using their legislative power
trying to [__] find anything they can
that will damage Joe Biden's attempt to
rerun as president any lies that they
can absolutely perpetuate out there the
real [__] [__] that is corruption is
right in their face but here's uh James
Comer this was uh earlier this week on
CNN talking about the evidence that he
has seen quote unquote evidence
that he has seen that is the Biden
family being corrupt and now I'm doing
the Donald Trump bunny ears thing Jesus
Christ these [__] people you see what
they got me doing God damn it
here's James Comer talking about the
evidence non-evidence that it is
unethical maybe not unethical it should
be illegal he wants it to be illegal but
it's not here it is listen it's [__]
dumb [__] but here we go so as chairman
of the house oversight committee you
have been investigating members of Joe
Biden's family and their business
with the bidens have you found anything
illegal while he was actually in office
well we found a lot that's certainly
unethical oh certainly sweetenly well
certainly you remember the three seasons
well certainly yet certainly uh
unethical by your standards but who
Jesus Christ
what what what could possibly meet the
standards of unethical if if James Comer
isn't on TV this morning on every single
[__] station that he can get on
talking about how Clarence Thomas's wife
took money for a court decision for
Leonard Leo's non-profit on how they
were trying to strip away rights out of
this Voting Rights Act of Southerners
particularly people of color and
minorities in Southern States oh that's
because it benefits James Comer
politically and it keeps him [__]
elected in States like I don't know
Kentucky you [__] piece of [__]
sorry get pissed off but let's listen to
how he's gonna tell us what evidence
non-evidence he has he doesn't have [__]
it's all a [__] lie we found a lot
that should be illegal the the line is
blurry oh my God it should be he wants
it to be unethical he wants it to be
illegal that's what he wants let's keep
listening to this [__] let's see if
we can smell what he's stepping in as to
what is legal and not legal with respect
to family influence peddling oh
getting [__] patents from China
because you're the you're the you're the
president's daughter and you work at the
White House or maybe you're a White
House staff member and you're Jared
Kushner and you're receiving billions
with a B from Saudi Arabia you
[__] why do you think it pisses
me off
when I hear right Wingers talking about
the Deep state
and these [__] wouldn't know
the Deep state if it sat on their
[__] face
sorry for growling into the microphone
but what else am I supposed to do
what the [__] else am I supposed to do
besides get completely pissed off about
this [__] ridiculous but you know
it'll continue to go on and on and on
let's see if we have any new uh breaking
news or stories no kellyanne Conway
George Conway Mike Pence
he's trending what the [__] happened now
is there breaking news with Mike Pence
oh my God
[Laughter]
uh oh we were saying earlier that birds
of a feather flock together right I
don't know if this is why Mike Pence is
is trending
but God damn
if this is why whoosh okay so apparently
um there's someone
um a republican called Joshua craft God
damn I gotta look this up Joshua who the
[__] is Joshua craft he's a he's a
[__] child porn possession possession
he's been charged with it
um
craft not like craft cheese like
Craftsman
um let's see if there's is there a
[__] story on this uh
it's someone is Bexar
uh Dara in the chat maybe they got a
handle on who this [__] Joshua craft
is uh oh Indiana Republican arrested for
um child pornography
Johnathan or Joshua excuse me craft uh
listen to this was arrested uh April 11
2013.
so just last month for possession of
child pornography craft ran as a
republican for the Otto Creek Township
Trustee for Vigo County in 2022 is
Facebook uh photos of crab with former
vice president Mike Pence and attorney
general
Todd rokita and photos of his family
crafts has been held a ten thousand
dollar bail
um so here is the um
oh my god oh man
um so here is um here it is
the USA singers here's here's Mike Pence
hanging out with his buddy Joshua Kraft
here's the guy you see his name tag
there Joshua Kraft this is the guy that
ran for the in the township he's an
Indiana Republican and apparently Mike
Pence likes him Mike Pence endorses him
it almost looks like and says here's
Mike Pence with his buddy Joshua craft
who's got arrested for possession in
child porn Republicans are the party of
groomers perfect pedo sickos psychos
rapists and child traffickers and
deviants
vote blue save America
from these disgusting creeps the U.S
singer says I agree but there it is
there it is it's not surprising that
Mike Pence is trending because he's out
there promoting endorsing and taking
pictures with
people that are being charged with
possession of child porn listen when
they keep talking about kids genitalia
it's them that are obsessed with it
they're they're [__] obsessed with it
in Missouri I I mentioned this time and
time again man
mention it time and time again
in Missouri
the governor is considering holding a
special session to talk about student
athletes and their genitalia I'm not
[__] you they're gonna have a
special session
to [__] talk about underage kids
genitals that is what they're going to
do
it's [__] crazy ass [__]
it's Insanity they're [__] weirdos
they're creeps I told you yesterday I
was talking to one of my friends who are
brainwashed by these [__]
and his first response from me calling
Dylan Mulvaney as she
I'm not [__] you I use the pronoun
she on Dylan Mulvaney and his first
[__] instinct is to correct me on the
pronoun
as if as if the pronoun was the most
important part of the what we were
talking about in the first place
he was triggered by the pronoun not me I
wasn't triggered by it and his first
instinct was to tell me it's a it's a
man because Dylan mulmaney has a penis
went straight for the genitalia I was
like man you're smart enough to
understand right that it sounds weird
that your first instinct in this
discussion is to go straight for the
person's genitalia that's [__] weird
man that's weird as [__]
that's weird stuff we are we are in a
[__] weird ass timeline you people
are believing propaganda that is getting
you to be hyper focused on other
people's genitalia it's [__] weird
[__]
um well
um and someone here on uh salty
Sylvester says questions their own
masculinity well that's that that's what
they're scared of right because they're
not running around these these these
white Christian nationalists these white
fragile men like Ethan that we watched
earlier they're not running around
[__] talking about trans men
they're not worried about someone who
looks like a man who who doesn't have a
penis right they're not worried about
that because they they wouldn't want to
have sex with that person who looks like
a man necessarily I mean you know that
people would know
so they're not worried about what
genitalia that that guy has they're
worried about a woman that they may that
they may find attractive that they may
you know get a boner over
and that that oh my God if they found
out that that woman that they may find
attractive has a penis well that makes
them gay and that's exactly what it is
they're hyper focused on trans women
that's why they're focused on women's
health care and banning it
that's why they're focused in these
states to make sure women
quote their definition of women in
Missouri they train they're passing
along to marry 12 year old girls
12 year olds
they're trying they're trying in States
to get rid of drugs
Health Care for Women ban them
they're banning procedures for women to
save their lives
I don't know if you see the through line
here
but these white
privileged fragile men
are trying to put their [__] foot on
the necks of women
people of color
trans people anyone who isn't their
demographic
that's the entire Point hell that's the
whole point here in Missouri them trying
to pass laws to make a pregnant woman
not being able to get a divorce
are no consent divorce get the [__] out
of here so you're saying as long as a
man doesn't consent
because that's what they mean folks
because when they want to consent for 12
year olds to get married they're not
talking about 12 year olds they're not
talking about 12 year old boys getting
married that's not what they want
they're talking about them as men
marrying 12 year old girls and their
parents giving consent
um political Tea says here I'm a trans
guy and they will ignore me and go off
about trans women it's got to be about
the fear of Attraction and power over
women exactly they can't have power over
trans women and it frightens them that's
right that's right and not not only that
because I know I knows I knows me of
plenty of these [__] fragile white
males
it literally is that they put themselves
in a position that if they've found a
woman attractive and they wanted to have
sex with that woman and found out
that that woman has a penis that would
make them gay
it threatens it threatens their little
lizard brain they can't wrap their heads
around how attraction works
they have no clue that it's just your
eyeballs that are attracting man
it's just your eyeballs dude
it's it doesn't mean that you're gay
she can be sexy even if she's a trans
woman it's a thing that can happen
and just because it confuses you doesn't
mean that person can't be that thing
it's it's a you problem it's a you
problem and it's a problem when these
Republicans continue to seem to endorse
and back a bunch of child pornographers
and pedophiles they're trying to marry
children
it really does seem like a problem Mike
Pence
what are you guys doing for Cinco de
Mayo let's talk about that let's talk
about that for a second and we only got
about 10 minutes left here on the show
let's talk about Cinco de Mayo I want to
talk to you guys let's shoot this [__]
that's right we're gonna shoot this [__]
here at the end
you guys can ask me a question you can
give shout outs
um there too um
to uh about Cinco de Mayo what you guys
are gonna do what are you guys gonna do
this weekend they're supposed to be like
a live a live show where I'm at and a
friend of mine uh wants me to go hang
out at a live show we're gonna listen to
some music so I think that maybe what we
do now oh by the way speak up last last
night
um we we went and saw the Marvel movie
and the new Guardians of the Galaxy
which is great it's a good movie I I'll
tell you I'll be honest with you the
first part of it
it's slow it's slow but it's worth it it
is worth it I don't think it's the best
Gardens Guardians of the Galaxy movie I
know I I I I I definitely wouldn't put
it as the best of that series but it's
still a good movie it's not the worst
Marvel movie either it's not like the
first Thor movie or something
uh some people are saying they're seeing
it tonight yeah I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna throw any es spoilers there's no
spoilers
um but it is worth it it is worth it it
was a good movie if you like Marvel
movies you'll like this one now there's
a lot of funny spots in it as there is
in most the garden galaxy uh movies what
are you guys doing what are you guys
doing for Cinco de Mayo
um me I mean i e or no me l e
on the twitch says Tony there's a music
festival all weekend here Beach Festival
amazing uh bands on the sand that sounds
cool
sounds cool I like light music I mean I
like music in general but I like live
music what else you guys doing
some people are are getting stoned but
Regina
get stoned baby hell yeah I've lost it
where you guys are typing fast that they
oh man oh man uh someone said something
about Marvel movies and dark Pepsi says
I'm fatigued with Marvel Marvel movies
at the moment you know
um we were talking about this last night
that it's incredible that Marvel has
been able to sustain
um this amount of blockbuster hits with
this uh this collection of Marvel
Universe movies and it's been like 15
years since the first Iron Man and when
when the first Iron Man came out so it's
um it's crazy
uh yeah there you go storm Virgil says
Tony is woke Marvel Disney shill
confirmed
Mark me down I guess I don't know I like
the Marvel movies there's a lot of
things about there's a lot of you know
I'm a Star Wars fan but I don't like the
television series really I didn't I yeah
and you can [__] [__] on me all you
want I didn't really like the
Mandalorian uh it's just too much like
like I want to watch a movie right I
don't want to watch a whole [__]
thousand episodes and then the other
thing that I don't like about the Marvel
thing and the Star Wars thing to be
quite honest with you is you have to
watch all of it to know all the [__]
that's happening sometimes and it kind
of pisses me off like come on do we have
do we have to do this to where we gotta
we gotta watch every single minute of
all the content to get what we're saying
a hundred percent of the time it's kind
of stupid it really is
um and a lot of people ask me why I
repeat the same things are the same kind
of ideas over and over that that's why
that's why because I don't want people
who haven't been watching the content
here on the Donnie Michael Show and like
a year ago I want them to be up to speed
so that's why it has the same tone and
the same ring to it sometimes it's
because of that
I don't want them to have to go watch
every single show to get caught up with
what we're talking about here on the
Tony Michaels podcast so
um the ideas is is to give commentary on
what's going on do do you have female
emojis what what does that mean where on
Facebook
is there do I have to set it that way
Paz Barron says um I don't know what
that means like I mean I know the
difference between male and female
emojis but do I have to do I have to set
it somehow because we've been trying to
get the emotes whatever that is on
Twitch the twitch users can can tell you
about that because I don't even really
know what that is
um but if I can set it somehow or change
it I I would be happy to to look into it
because yeah I mean it doesn't make me
any difference we're still trying to do
the emotes thing
um over on Twitch I gave Gabe the the
access and it's still not letting him in
the post the emotes or whatever they are
there's like little stickers
and if you want to figure out what they
are just go over to Twitch
um and someone can send me a private
message I think you can private message
me on Twitch and and forgive me if it
takes a couple days because again I know
I always get around to him
[Music]
caretaker says going to see something
else for the movies this weekend like a
Mario movie again oh you know that's
kind of funny I was thinking about that
last night that the Chris Pratt has like
two of the top movies right now the
Mario movie where he he voices
um Mario and then uh the uh The Gardens
of the Galaxy movie obviously
what else are you guys doing for Cinco
de Mayo
what else you guys get to do
you have any questions for me again
we're shooting the [__] so if you want
to throw a question in there I'm not
opposed to it it's Friday we're ramping
up the show so
um yeah someone said I loved taking my
kids to the Mario movie it was pretty
good we went and seen the Mario movie uh
several weeks ago I think when it first
came out it's been three weeks already
or a month I don't know it's been uh
it's been at number one for for a while
um as far as that goes
what am I doing for Cinco de Mayo I'm
I'm going um tonight we're just we're
gonna go hang out with some friends at a
live music thing and that's it for for a
little while
um I think it lasts still I don't know I
don't know how long it lasts but we're
gonna go do that
we're gonna go watch some live music and
maybe we'll go eat some dinner or
something who knows
um
did you ever go to day on the green I
don't know what that means
did you ever go today on the green I'm
not sure what that means I don't know
um
what else are you guys doing for are you
guys getting drunk I mean I might drink
I don't know I had my fair share on
Wednesday what drink hmm
what's my top favorite country artist
yeah there's a question let's see
um
well Garth would probably have to be at
the very top I like Garth Brooks
um another another great country I was
Shania Twain she's got a lot of good
songs
um Shania is a hell of a [__] artist
so Shania
um you know I I I I like George Jones
um and a George you know Alan Jackson
sounds a lot like George Jones to me so
maybe I'd put those at number three well
let's see who else do I do I really
really like
um and and then a lot of times it's the
the stuff I like to sing
um but more than anything it's it's the
the sound of the artist another country
music artist and a lot of people
consider him a folk artist but he's one
of my favorite artist artists but I
think a lot of his sound sounds like
country and he sings a lot of country
music and he's written a lot of country
music is John Prine a lot of people
haven't heard of John Prine because he's
more of a he wasn't a mainstream artist
he was more of a folk artist but it was
country folk music but John Prine is I
consider one of the greatest
songwriters
of all time so I like I like John Prine
his music but I I will say the fifth you
know George Strait is one of the
greatest country music singers but he's
not one of my favorite
um but if I I had to put someone in
there as far as one of the greatest
voices of all time man it's hard because
I really want to throw dolly in their
Dolly Parton and Reba Reba McIntyre it's
like those two Reba darling so okay so
top five I'm gonna go with Garth Brooks
uh Shania Twain George Jones Reba
McIntyre and Dolly Parton that's
probably what I'm gonna go with
um for country music singers again if
we're doing writers it would have to be
a little different but that's what I'm
gonna go with out of those people that's
where I'm gonna put my top five so I
mean uh big staff fan says Reba's my
number one Reba has uh just a
I mean it's just like earth-shattering
voice like there's no one I mean if
you're if you're gonna like okay sing
sing a really good country song with a
famous
country female country artist voice
you're gonna pick Shania Dolly Ariba
right am I right or am I wrong I mean
you may go like
um you know like Trisha Yearwood or
Carrie Underwood or something like that
but I mean dolly dolly Shania Twain and
Reba McEntire has some of it's just
they're just [__] phenomenal they're
voices so it's phenomenal um Benny Loco
says Willie Willie turned 90. Willie
definitely Willy's definitely up there
for singers but I would put Willie and
John Prine on the songwriters uh top
five so they're really good singers
um they've really good artists but
Willie and John Prine would definitely
be at the very top of the songwriters uh
Chris Stapleton is another great
songwriter I don't know if you guys know
that uh he's written some fantastic
songs a lot of songs that you've heard
that other artists sing is Chris
Stapleton so he's a he's a great writer
he's a great song country songwriter as
well
um so there's that there's that I know a
few things about country music just a
few just a few what else do you guys get
you guys get any more questions we're
winding up here maybe I'll answer one
more question if I can find one here
what else you got
we won't talk um any more um country
music but political thesis Reba is the
queen
I don't know Dolly Parton and Reba may
be the princess of country music Dolly I
think is probably the the queen I would
disagree there but you know not too much
of a disagreement
um uh Johnny Cash
Western not country so Johnny Cash
um
it's
it's funny in that moment in history
where they were charting on both charts
because country was different than than
it was in the 70s 80s and 90s you know
countries in the 50s and 60s 40s 50s 60s
really was completely different right
but Elvis was double charted Johnny Cash
was double charted a lot of these a lot
of these singers then were double
charted on the Rock charts and
uh the country charts so it's kind of in
that era of Music it you could almost
consider them one and the same so
let's see one more question
how long have I been married
17 years I've been married we've
celebrated our 17 I know I don't
probably most people say I don't look
old enough but I am old enough to be
married for 17 years I I turned 38 this
year so we were very young when we got
married and we stayed married and you
know marriage is marriage is hard work
it really is it's hard work it doesn't
that's why that's why when someone asked
me should I get married I'm like
I don't know it's quite it's quite the
hard work
um to to to build a marriage and stay
married
um even if you love each other very much
it's um it's it's a partnership and
Partnerships
are you have to work at them you have to
work at them you have to compromise and
as humans we know this don't always like
to do that we don't always like to do
that so and I'm very lucky because I
married way up way up so I'm very lucky
and I'm not um
post saying that live on air I I'm very
I'm very lucky and I married way up
she's probably listening then soon she
might be listening so that's the other
reason why she doesn't watch the show
because uh where my studio is at and if
she's in a certain part of the house she
can hear everything I'm saying so that's
why I would say something
uh Marge Margie says what do your kids
think of your podcast
I mean
my teenage son son doesn't think much of
it he thinks I think I'm cool he's a
teenager though right my daughter my
daughter loves the fact that I have a
YouTube channel because you know they
love YouTube
um so and and the other thing that my
son does think is funny is that some of
the haters meme on Reddit because he
likes Reddit a lot so
I get memed on Reddit which I guess
gives me some credibility with the hey
hey my hip young kids
well we made him full circle full circle
back to Steve Buscemi everybody
I want you to have a safe and and fun
weekend if you're celebrating Saint go
to mile please stay safe and all your
celebrations and anywhere you go out
there
um please stay safe and come visit us on
the YouTube channel the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to subscribe right
here on YouTube and download every
single episode on Apple's Spotify and
Google make sure to use your Amazon
Prime subscription that they give you
for twitch because you get one you get
one free subscription with your Amazon
Prime account and if you link that Prime
account to your Twitch account you can
give us that free subscription it
doesn't cost you a single nickel and it
gives us a couple bucks every single
month it's kind of a cool way to support
the show monetarily
if you already have a Prime account
um so anyone out there that has a Prime
account can link their Twitch account to
it and you can give us that one free
subscription and also come visit us at
patreon just go to thetonymichaels.com
uh the Tony michaels.com select the
patreon link or go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels we'll be doing a Sunday
rant this Sunday as I do every Sunday
special exclusive content over on
patreon so go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or the Tony michaels.com I know
I didn't get the rake let the meat rake
we're so close we just have a few more
changes to make so go to patreon.com you
can see the initial design I'll be
posting over the weekend when we get the
final design there first and then I'll
be releasing um the merch and you will
have first access on patreon to the
merch but I'm hoping by Monday morning
we will have the brand new let them eat
rake merch everybody have a safe and
happy weekend please please celebrate
Cinco de Mayo safe we'll see you on
Monday same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoy the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn head ass Beacon